hi I'm KJ Appa and this is the wide
order complete interview okay here we go
why does KJ up not have an accent in
Riverdale
because KJ after is an actor and he has
to do an American accent when he's
on-screen our KJ Appa and Cole Sprouse
friends know rkg Optima and Camille
Amanda is related that would be really
weird if we were related kind of it
anyway is KJ up a dead know I'm not a
dad I will be one day
looking forward to it is KJ upper left
handed no I'm right handed is KJ upper
hair real my hair is real the color of
it is not real my real color is the same
color as my eyebrows any questions it is
KJ up a perfect no nobody's perfect the
only perfect human being that walked the
earth with Jesus is KJ up a Polynesian
yes he is Polynesian is from Sawa his
father is from Sawa and that is where
his salmon blood is descended from it is
ketchup and Star Wars no I'm not into
Star Wars because I was a Star Wars but
no I'm not it's ours this K dad were
really singing in Brevard oh yeah it is
but they put lots of auto-tune in there
for me shoutout to the auto-tune guys
making me look like a legend is KJ up
are related to Tommy Lee Jones I don't
even know who Tommy Lee Jones is Oh
Tommy Lee Jones yeah I know Tommy Lee
juck do I look like Tommy Lee Jones oh
no way do it that's pretty funny yeah no
I'm not related to Tommy Lee Jones
how does KJ opera cover his Tarot I am
actually very lucky because I have a
team of very
woman on the Riverdale set who come
three hours early for me to cover all my
toes they do a phenomenal job do I
particularly enjoy sitting there for
three hours getting everything covered
up not really did I decide to get all
these terrorists yes I did so I'd
probably deserve it but woman who do it
thank you you know who you are
a very blessed to have you in my life
sure these are my Tet
sorry sound man putting this back on
how did KJ up become an actor I never
really actively pursued acting it was my
mother actually put me into an agency as
a 13 year old boy because my sister was
a model I ended up doing an audition
when I was six name for a TV show and
that's how it all started how tall is
Kadapa in feet
I'm six foot six foot how much does KJ
up a bench way I weigh approximately it
changes every week but I weigh
approximately hundred and sixty-six
pounds
how is capa she's doing great is it's
very much in love right now what is KJ
upper what does catch up his real name
my real name is Kenneth E James Kennedy
I'm named after my father
it's a someone named it's like the Sun
Ward name of Kennedy was named after JFK
actually what hospital was KJR per
warning I was born wait Tucker to
hospital I'm a Westie boy from New
Zealand shout out to all the West he's
out there all the bogans in New Zealand
what color are KJ up his eyes I don't
know get a close-up there you go
they write heavy what is KJ's favorite
food watermelon actually watermelon has
always been my favorite food as a young
child yeah and I've said what is KJ
upper what is catch ever
that's a good question actually
I ask myself that every single day did
KJ up go to college in New Zealand we
call high school college I went to high
school so yeah I wait to call it did KJ
Appa
break his hand he did he broke his right
hand during the filming of season 2 I
believe it was Ken KJ Appa dance I like
to think that I can dance a lot of
people would say otherwise do I really
know how to dance am I am I you know did
I learn dancing no I don't really know
how to dance but anyone can dance if you
believe in yourself y KJ oppas parents
my father's name is 2pi and my mother's
name is Tessa this is really something
people cool who is KJ oppas girlfriend I
bet Oh best friend best friend I have
many best friends I don't like to rank
my best friends who does KJ APPA looked
like I had people shout out Edward
Cullen to me on a regular basis when I'm
walking on the street people shout it
out of cars things like that I'm not
even kidding it people do that all the
time and I don't really think I do look
like him but I would think that that's a
compliment
he's a good-looking dude who is KJ APPA
married to wouldn't you just like to
know that okay that's that one done are
we doing another one is KJ up alive
yes he's alive and he's well and in love
is KJ upper nice you can decide that for
yourself I think I'm a nice guy where
does KJ upper come from they come from a
place called El tiro
the land of the long white cloud aka New
Zealand where is KJ up where right now
KJ oppa right now is sitting and the
river del student lounge with a bunch of
Legends recording there's a whole lot of
people here behind you that you don't
actually know a here in Canada I'm in
Canada Vancouver to be specific what was
Katie oppas first movie the first movie
that I ever shot was a movie called a
dogs purpose the director was lasse
hallström and
oh there with Britt Robertson Dennis
Quaid and a few other PEO Lipton of the
legendary actors it's very proud to be a
part of that film and it will always be
very special to me
how is cage ever discovered how does
cage a up change his accent just does it
I just do it I don't know how all right
guys well that was the wired order of
complete interview my name is KJ thank
you so much for having me